Thank You Camille and thank you Michael
for having me to your class and thank
you everyone for being here today we
turn the lights out a little bit I like
talking in the dark this is pretty
amazing i don't think i've ever had so
many screens for a presentation computer
science you guys get all the funding you
know it's like um but so i'm going to
share with you today probably really
well about twenty years of work but very
quickly some earlier works but there's
just something it's the only thing that
will be about the election i promised
this is actually these are two images i
made for a a project that artist is
doing in las vegas called dishing it out
and she invited artists to do
interpretations of current political
candidates and she's printing these on
plates you know like member you know
candidate play to have you ever seen
those and then on election night there's
going to be a smashing party which is
quite fun so but to take you into my
work just some some quick background on
some earlier projects that and this is
the this is the work that actually led
me into engaging computer games did a
whole series of works in the late 90s
dealing with discarded and dead and non
functioning computer mice running
computer labs we're going through my saw
all the time this is when they had track
balls and they would get all hairy and
die and all that kind of stuff and this
was the one piece in this whole series
that i made it was actually functional
this is called my hardest mouse and it's
essentially what you see here is a an
appendage that connected to my apple
desktop mouse and all of my computer
time was tracked so everything i did
made marks on on fine art rag paper so i
was using traditional materials and
digital technology kind of combination
and i invented this thing i was like
gosh what i'm going to do in about the
same time I started playing computer
games just kind of curious my students
were getting involved in these things
and they were coming as freebies with
stuff we ordered for our lab so I was
like God okay what's going to make
interesting marks with this device and
it was I was like oh playing computer
games so I was playing on
at the time the original iteration of
this game and I basically use the artist
mouse to play four levels of the game
replacing my my mouse pad with with
paper right so each of these is playing
a level of the game and this is a
literal mapping and translation of all
of my game activity from you know when
you're playing these games your mouse is
going and you're doing all that stuff I
thought the marks really interesting and
it was this kind of curious thing that I
couldn't make if I tried and it was this
recording of this computer time right so
I land up going on and doing a whole
series of drawings abstract drawings
recording all of my computer time each
of these above this is called work play
the series each of these is about a
month of all of my computer times and
basically kind of rotating a piece of
paper about this big as it filled up
with marks and so that was writing memos
sending emails surfing the internet
playing games grading student work etc
and so it's like this mapping of work
and play this one actually is the first
larger piece that I did and this was
actually done at my my desk when I was
chair of my department so it has much
more sort of boring marks anyone who's
done that kind of work knows what I'm
talking about what this work led to was
well just more gameplay and actually
kind of engaging computer games as an
aspect of my creative practice which
seemed kind of subversive in its own
right these games were you know
distraction entertainment just just for
fun right but this was about the time
when they started emerging into online
spaces right and you had quake going on
live in different games and I noticed
the the texting that would go on in the
game space right that you're playing
this amazing virtual world blowing
things up shooting each other but the
only way could communicate with each
other was through this 19th century
invention of the keyboard and I thought
there was a nice kind of analog digital
sort of thing going on there and that's
where I got this idea about what about
doing something else with this and
started thinking about these online
spaces as a new type of public
bass and why do I have to go in a space
and do this prescribed activity of
killing each other why couldn't I do
other things so I tried this experiment
2001 I was on sabbatical and it was just
one of these ideas that was kind of like
well let's try this and so I went into a
Star Trek elite force Voyager online as
allen ginsberg and rather than play the
game i use the text messaging system to
recite howl word-for-word over about a
seven hour period and during this entire
process I'm getting killed and getting
reincarnated I'm typing and getting
killed we incarnate I didn't shoot you
know my basically was a neutral
interloper and it was just this very
strange experience I had no idea whether
this was interesting important whether
it was even art and I think that's
oftentimes when you get to the most
interesting experimental places as an
artist as those places that you don't
know if their art you know and it landed
up actually being one of the first
examples of an artist actually
performing in a computer game space head
it's a modus operandi that I just kind
of adapted into different context and
has led to a whole bunch of different
things 2003 this was a project where I
decided to up my game if you will I
invited five of my students to join me
and we did a performance in a quake
arena of entire episode from the TV show
friends and each of us was in character
as Monica Chandler but I can't remember
the names right now but we went in and I
actually transcribed an episode and we
went into the game space and it was
total chaos it was basically so there
were six people who are essentially easy
prey right and we're all typing and
we're getting killed and the rules where
you don't shoot you just wherever you
appear you start typing and you do your
dialogue we ended up doing a larger
production of this the first one was
done in our computer lab with two of the
points of view projected we did a second
version in the Shepherd gallery at the
University Nevada Reno with all six
points of view projected 12 channels of
sound and we're all speaking as we're
typing in
dialogue rights was this completely
chaotic insane experience of sound
vision you know headshot don't know just
and you know this totally a name
dialogue from friends and and it was it
was meant as a kind of cultural mashup
of these two kind of really simple forms
of entertainment they're very similar
right when you're in a shooter game you
always know what's going to happen and
by the end of it you forget about it
same thing with a sitcom right it's like
it's never there's never anything really
quite unique or interesting that happens
in those contexts but this was just a
way of kind of bringing these these two
things together and see what see what
happens the work became much more
serious after 911 I've always been
involved in kind of cultural criticism
and playing with kind of pop culture and
done some work about war and things in
the in the 90s but 911 and this actually
really sort of propelled me into really
where I am today this is the website for
the 911 memorial competition where you
can still go in all 5201 entries that
were sent in from around the world are
available to review through the website
and remember when this came out and this
is about just less than a year into the
invasion of Iraq and I remember
speculating seeing this and saying wow
this is pretty amazing that we're doing
this there's this public sharing of this
competition process and also that we're
rightfully seeking to memorialize the
victims of 911 but at the same time I
was troubled in thinking about how many
more thousands of innocents had already
been killed in the invasion of Iraq
which was propagated on us in large part
through 911 the Bush administration etc
setter analyze etc and I was trouble
there was deeply troubled and thinking
gosh will never do this kind of process
to memorialize the civilian casualties
in Iraq right and then I started
thinking about oh but of course we'll
have the eventual memorial to all the
soldiers who are dying in Iraq you know
instead of thinking about the Vietnam
Veterans Memorial and all that kind of
stuff in any way
it all sort of gelled into two projects
one this game came out july 4th 2002 and
i remember when this came out and I was
doing these game interventions and this
is the america's army game which was a
recruiting a marketing tool developed by
the Defense Department to recruit young
people into the military and to present
a positive view of the United States
military abroad remember this came out
and I was thinking oh this is like
something needs to happen in this game
but it's a serious game right it's it's
actually part of this process of
bringing young people to a place where
they possibly will kill other people
were be killed in real life and this
just this kind of all gelled with the
911 kind of Memorial process to become a
project where I essentially enter the
america's army game and this is
documented
so
basic concept was I go into this game my
avatars name is dead in Iraq you're
gonna lights down even more please like
way down thank you I go into this game
as dead in Iraq you are you know part of
a platoon of other soldiers who are
online from who knows where and rather
than play the game I drop my weapon and
I go and I find just a kind of location
where I haven't go to point of view over
the space and if you look up on the top
left corner you'll see me begin to type
and I type in the name age service
branch and date of death of every
American soldier who died in the Iraq
war started this in 2006 actually was 23
rd October 14,000 generally get killed
very quickly and at that point you kind
of hover over your dead avatar and I
keep typing and and this is a chronology
of of death from the war and I and I
looked at this as a kind of a memorial
in the same sense of carving those names
on to the granite Chris a Vietnam
veterans of oil sheiks love you but also
as a kind of cautionary gesture a a
protest and a memorial let me get back
to my powerpoint here and it was it was
a way of intervening in this space of
kind of closing a loop between the war
and this virtual game developed by the
Defense Department to draw people into
that conflict and in fact there were
people who played that game and landed
up dying in the conflict you know there
was this connection between play and
reality and in a way of as a citizen
intervening into this space to raise
questions raise awareness and to kind of
confront the sort of fallacious nature
of the game there's no blood there's no
gore you just die and it was designed in
such a way that anyone over 13 get
downloaded without parental permission
etc
reactions of other players were Swift
and generally harsh r.i.p this is a game
something that would be said all the
time this is a game this is a game this
is a game this is dead please this is
not the forum to do this man will all
the hackers go play ping pong or
something I don't give a [ __ ] and
getting kicked from the game was
ultimately my measure of success because
that mean that everybody else in that
particular game had been paying
attention to the point where they all
had to vote to remove me from that
server so it's a way of kind of getting
inside people's heads with information
that was contrary to the you know it's
propaganda game essentially right and it
was a way of getting into that space
with a contrary message just sort of
subvert the the meaning of this context
I could talk a lot about this and
hopefully we'll have some questions
about it I can go more in depth but I
want to move on to some other work here
these are this is related of course to
the American army project the americas
army game has action figures it has
graphic novels comic books a whole
website with forums etc but i bought the
the action figures and i actually
kitbash to create a version of that
image a different type of action hero
one that was a fallen soldier and i show
this because it kind of connects to a
current project that's more related to
drones but there's doing a presentation
about this work and actually getting
this image the searching for america's
army action figure and on google i
noticed I was like why I do like
America's Army to action figure and it's
like oh there's my work there's my work
there's my work there's my work there's
my you know it was a strange accidental
intervention into that into google image
space right and that that kind of stuck
with me i was like wow that's kind of
fascinating and actually kind of
rewarding to see that that has happened
so anyone who goes look for an image for
america's army action figure will come
across this different kind of america's
army action figure
and I could talk for probably hours
about the america's army project it was
quite pivotal changed my life I found
myself under attack from people emailing
me interviewed by the press was on NPR
CNN etc and it was a very pivotal kind
of experience and my growth and change
as an artist and really sort of
solidified my kind of acceptance of
myself as a sort of artists / activist
and kind of really sort of firmly
planting myself in the political realm
but again back to this piece and of
course my primary concern when when
looking at this was civilian casualties
in Iraq and just some some statistics
and guesstimates and estimates about the
casualties from the Iraq conflict just
to put it in context like we don't know
right and there were quotes about not
doing body counts and you know all this
kind of stuff it's like we don't as
Americans we don't concern ourselves
particularly with the victims of our
military interventions period amen right
and that's that's horrible and I wanted
to do something to address this and
looking at that competition site I
thought now maybe I can just flip the
code on that site and create a different
call for entries for some you know for
memorials and landed up doing a
completely autonomous project called
Iraqi memorial org and it was a call for
artists for anyone architects whomever
to submit imagine memorial proposals for
the civilian casualties in Iraq and land
up getting just over 200 entries you can
go to the site today it's a really kind
of has become a kind of archive of
projects there's some really interesting
stuff and a lot of artists actually sent
in works they actually done has kind of
proposals and I'll ended up accepting
those as well I'd invite you to go to
the site there's some pretty amazing
stuff on there that landed up morphing
into a traveling exhibition I actually
had jurors curators museum directors
writers who acted as jurors we had to
sounds of review and they each chose
their top five entries there was no
winner to the competition because of
course the memorial would never be built
right it was it was a symbolic gesture
and the fact that there was no winner
was part of that part of the meaning
behind the work but the five the five
pieces chosen by each curator landed up
in a list i might i think we did an
exhibition of about fifty something of
these that traveled and they each artist
was invited to recreate the proposal has
a proposal board the same size as the
911 proposal boards and this travel this
was at university of at arena was at
work scouring san jose and the most
interesting was in new york city at the
elizabeth foundation for the arts and
this exhibition opened on September
ninth 2011 two days before the 911
memorial was dedicated in New York City
and this had artifacts performances was
a really pretty intense experience
Gandhi did these two projects it was a
couple years of really involved in his
intense kind of work dealing with death
and memorial and memory and protests
getting lots of online abuse getting
flamed getting bodily threatened my
people but amazing and just completely
passionate about that work but one of
things that happen was there are many
stories written about dead in Iraq in
particular on salon and wired and all
kinds of places and I started reading
the comment sections right and it was
just this kind of vitriol if you know
someone should go break this guy's legs
and that is unpatriotic and support our
troops etc and I decided to start to
engage those commenters as myself and I
would go in with my name my picture and
say I'm the one doing this and here's
why and it got to this point where that
became kind of part of the furtherance
of the work and that I was engaged in
this kind of dialogue with this context
of anonymous commenters and in one of
those situations
one of those commenters accused me of
having a Gandhi complex and that kind of
astounded me you know that someone would
think of that as a pejorative you know
an insult and it just kind of also is
like wow you know if you say so you know
like I'm okay with that and I had had an
idea about moving from text-based
performance of doing some kind of a some
kind of a bodily walking performance
across game spaces perhaps walking
across different computer games just to
explore us as a kind of land or of game
space right then it is just I was
reading about protest because there's
all kinds of people saying why are you
why are you doing this thing in
America's Army why don't you go on to
the steps of the Federal Building and
I'd say this is the federal building
this is actual government property
you're playing on in a virtual space
right but it also led me to do research
and reading about the history of
nonviolent protest and resistance and of
course all roads in that sense lead to
Gandhi and that just kind of connected
with this and it became an idea and
Camille mention it at the start of our
introduction but the essential component
of this was to go into second life and
created the Gandhi avatar and equipped a
walk fit treadmill which is a
non-powered dreadmill it's actually when
you have to push to walk made by Nordic
Track and I set this up with a very
simple sensor system and magnets and a
little switch reed switch that I hacked
into my forward arrow key on my keyboard
and my steps on the treadmill became
Gandhi steps in second life and I walked
over 26 days 240 miles all over Second
Life interacting with avatars residents
and this was an insanely joyful
experience and and coming off of these
other two very intense projects it was
really and it was part of embracing part
of Gandhi's working philosophy was that
he bought joy to his work right he was
doing really intense dangerous stuff and
his life was threatened he was thrown in
jail etc but he did it with a sense of
joy and positiveness
that was really helpful to me and going
in as Gandhi in this game you know I'd
wander around in it and I would navigate
towards a little bit of green dots or
other residents and I would just
navigate towards them and you get there
maybe like Gandhi what's up what are you
doing you know and then I described to
them oh my humans on a treadmill were
walking we're reenacting the salt march
would you like to join us and I'd give
them a gift of a walking stick and start
walking and there were time there were
some people followed me for several days
who would find me the next day and kind
of come in and it was an incredible
experience I went into it as kind of
conceptual performance thinking like
what would this be like and found myself
physically and psychologically just
totally shifted like changed I lost like
eight pounds I found myself in New York
City walking back to my apartment and
thinking I could click on people you
know like I had this that I was dreaming
about it and it just it inhabited my it
just you know i was eating sleeping
waking up going walking falling asleep
in it just it inhabited my life in a way
that it made it gave me a new
understanding of both kind of a
durational physical computer based
activity like mixed reality like what
that could do but it just it shifted me
in a way it was it's hard to describe
but that experience led to part of the
residency at IBM was having an
exhibition at the end of the residency
period and this is in the heart of
Chelsea art district there this huge
warehouse space and I was like I want to
make a giant Gandhi it's like how do I
do this and talking with other residents
came about with this came up with this
adapting a process pepakura which is a
papercraft software for making little
things on your desktop than that but I
adapted it to large scale so this is a
17-foot cardboard Gandhi from the
extracted data from second life he's 17
feet because that's the same height as
Michelangelo's David I was actually
Stanford researchers who discovered that
they thought it was 14 feet and they set
up this whole big scanning thing and
they actually had to add an attachment
to it because it was taller than all the
art historians had been saying for
decades but
thought it was appropriate considering
Gandhi David you know another kind of
David slaying Goliath I'll end up doing
three of these about one in New York
City was invited to build another one in
Guangzhou China and another one in in
Belgium that actually landed up going to
Belfast but it was this way of
representing in physical form the
significance of this experience right
I've gone on from there to do a number
of works dealing furthering interest in
computer gaming particularly shooter
games contemporary shooters and I
started extracting data from just just
interested in contemporary shooters
where you're fighting against terrorists
I thought was really interesting that
fifty percent of the players were
essentially reenacting being a terrorist
right these people that we are supposed
to hate and fear you know that you're
running around your teenage son is in
their bedroom running around playing as
a Taliban fighter killing Americans
right that's there's something very
strange about that so I started
extracting the data from these games and
this is actually the primary work that
came out of this there's some other
stuff that I hope to get to but these
are these are a pair of it's a Taliban
fighter holding a pistol and I'm
basically extracted the whole map and
then got down to the hands and remade
these as they're about four feet wide
out of white corrugated plastic and
they're when they're displayed they
almost look like marble and you kind of
like the kind of double take that people
do they see these things and then they
see the title they're called Taliban
hands it just kind of you know plays
with those those notions of terroristic
play and artfulness jumping this is
going to seem like a real tangent but
it's not what I did the Gandhi walk i
started thinking also about god i'd
really like to do some kind of
durational performance in real space
performance / protest and i came across
the across this quote this is part of
the quote if a concentrated solar power
system was built that was 100 mile 100
miles square and size this would be more
than enough to meet the country's entire
energy demand this by cliff chen from
the
concerned scientists he also says in the
American Southwest which is where I live
essentially in Nevada so I started
looking at the map of Nevada and
wondering like what does that mean what
does that translate to in this area
right here is the Nellis test and
training range the Nevada Test Site area
51 this is the largest military
peacetime military installation in the
world and it just so happens it is
essentially that area that the union of
concerned scientists have talked about
in terms of the space so you know this
right nevada test site this is where 928
nuclear tests above and below ground
taking place area 51 Groom Lake Nevada
of course where the aliens are
supposedly hit and all that but in fact
and in conducting research on on this
base this is actually where all of our
secret weapons aircraft have been tested
from the b-2 bomber to the b12 and two
drones this is where weaponized drones
were first tested and also discovering
that Creech Air Force Base which is in
the Nellis test and training range where
his command and control and training
base for drones and there's drones
flying from there right now on the other
side of the planet conducting missions
and learning more about the civilian
cost of our use of weaponized drones
abroad and I became really there's this
this project led to this kind of
interest and obsession with drones since
but let me talk about this particular
project so here again is the Nellis Air
Force range to reline around the public
roads to see what that distance was
whether you could surround this and it's
about 240 miles I remember correctly the
sorry 380 miles i'm wrong i did a
project where essentially i adapted a
long tail bicycle that was equipped with
solar panels and multi
cameras and GPS all kinds of technology
going on this trip and essentially I
made hundreds of pieces of white chalk
big white chalk that I cast and I rode
this bicycle around the entire nillas
test and training range to draw a circle
around him to identify a space that
could be used for other purposes this
took about 10 days very intense
durational experience was hot was windy
isolated but also an incredible
experience and just to sort of imagine
repurposing this land right to think
about why can we use this for this and
not for that you know it's just like
this basic question and it led to this
obsession with drones this was an image
that I did about the same time where I
basically found the top search result
for Predator drone took it off into
Photoshop and replaced and placed on the
fuselage using military font the word
cowardly it's cowardly drone series and
the intent of this is going back to that
America's Army action figure is taking
all these top research results from
google image search and placing us on
there and then putting these images back
online in the hope that they would
eventually find their way to to google
hang on a second it's not going forward
what is going on here here we go so if
you go to Google now and you type in
predator drone and you do an image
search and this is going to be a live
search here see there's my image and
there's another one so you know it's
again it's like this purposeful
manipulation of whatever the algorithm
is that Google uses to pick the top
search results and it's just this way
again kind of intervening in this public
image space I didn't know if it would
work land up working which was very cool
so that's that's an ongoing project I
did about 10
of no I did about 20 drones with
cowardly on there so the some reason
those two have have shown up and I'm
just leaving it there to see what
happens this is a this is a new video
what the [ __ ] the Afghani villagers
stoning bound predator drive I saw this
video and I had been invited by CSU
Fresno to actually create a public
artwork on their campus and this image
is kind of stuck with me and actually
drones crash all the time like their
fall out of the sky it's a routine
occurrence and there was something about
this image of resistance that I found
very very inspiring so they CSU
president approached me up making a
temporary public art work for their
campus I went on to their campus and I
worked for two weeks with student
volunteers and design students when we
actually constructed a full-size hundred
percent scale low polygon reproduction
of a Predator drone and this was really
interesting experience like working with
students coming and showing them how to
cut score etc and glue and we built this
drone and installed it out on the quad
and the main part of campus this is
stage one of this whole process and as
it looks as if it fell from the sky we
then had a performative reading by
Pakistani immigrants of names of
civilian drone casualty that have been
identified by the bureau of
investigative journalism and each
volunteer was given a card with a name
the date of death and the age of that
victim that were then invited to take a
pen and write on the surfaces of the
drone that information and was also
translated into her due by our
volunteers this was really a very moving
and powerful experience that the piece
was on display on campus for two months
I was actually in the flight path of air
force base nearby and I have some google
images from Google Earth of the piece
are quite interesting but this was a
community engagement public artwork a
protest and memorial and it was it was
just trying things seeing seeing what it
would be like this some of the
volunteers and the people actually
worked on the piece and I've heard
feedback from some of the faculty there
and many of the students say this was
like the most interesting thing they did
in their entire educational experience
which is very rewarding as an artist and
an educator this is a piece I did I was
a resident artist at Autodesk in San
Francisco I was on sabbatical in 2014-15
first piece I made this is called me and
my predator and it's essentially a piece
of headgear with a 170 second scale
plastic model of a Predator drone
attached to my head at a slight angle
and so it's like you're walking around
and it's it's a public performative
sculpture so I wore this walking up and
down the embarcadero in san francisco
it's a kind of thing like say hey
there's a drone and you'd be like what I
don't see anything you know it's a silly
piece but it's also bringing drones home
right bringing these these things that
are flying right now in our name on the
other side of the planet into the
immediate interior media presence one of
the things I've done with these works
and others is I've begun to post created
instructables around these works of
contemporary art and you guys know
instructables right it's basically place
where people put how to do this how to
cook how to make how to hack you know
all these kind of things it's like why
not how to make a contemporary artwork
and so I put these things on there so
it's personal drone system me and my
predator and the best thing well besides
of getting you know thousands of views
which is which is great is the the
comments section is just adorable so
people come on and they're like you know
what the [ __ ] how is this a drone this
is very miscategorized don't name it a
personal drone system if you glue it to
your hat that isn't a drone
I say you don't see a drone funny I
don't either you know nota and just and
it goes on like just people getting in
this kind of dialogue about about this
this artwork right and some people don't
have a such humor but that's okay but I
like that it's like getting out of it's
a way of getting out of the museum the
gallery the kind of you know like into
the real world where people function and
bringing something unexpected went on as
well to make use a laser cutter to
create a drone rubber stamp and this was
essentially to place a little green
drone over the White House notice the
empty space on the back of the
twenty-dollar bill and I was like huh
that needs a drone and so I made this
thing and then I posted this on Facebook
just saying hey you want one of these
and you know and I land up getting about
200 people responding to me and sent
them all drone stamps and so people have
been stamping drones on their money and
sending me pictures and this is the
website and drones we trust the Tumblr
site there's hundreds of examples of
cash that people have sent from all over
the United States and abroad I meant to
bring some drone stamp so you could
stand today and I forgot they're in my
bag in San Francisco apologies but you
can order your own and this kind of snow
ball went viral online there were a lot
of people writing about it talking about
it but it was a way of kind of again
bringing drones home like bringing them
into reality so that maybe you went to
the store and got some cash and there's
a drone over the White House you know
maybe your head is expanded a little bit
and maybe you're thinking about things
this again i made a an instructor about
how to do this and the comments on here
were even more intense intense political
argument dialogue going on about our
drone policies which is what the work is
all about right it's like to get people
to be thinking about these weapons that
are doing things on the other side of
planet as i speak so that that again is
very rewarding and i think a kind of
side side effect of this kind of work
i'll end up doing two more stamps this
is hands up don't shoot which i created
after the Ferguson
shooting this one as well there's
several thousand I'm sorry about a
thousand of these stamps out their
shared and in various exhibitions
surrounding the issue of police violence
also have done a piece called a sea
level rising and this is essentially
puts a rising sea level on your cash and
these as have we have as well been
shared widely and their people stamping
I do make a kit that I sell as well and
these are just sold to cover my costs
and the shipping basically so if you
want one of these go to the website and
I can send you one before I moved to
Scotland that'll get more expensive but
and this is a project you guys know beer
stats paintings of the West probably
seen his work Albert Bierstadt these are
amazing visualizations of the American
West large huge paintings that created
this kind of imagined frontier right and
they were actually very instrumental in
people like wow I want to go there so I
basically have taken numerous examples
of these works offline and made simple
gift files with a drone flying across
these classic bierstadt visualizations
of the West many of them involved Native
Americans Yosemite National Park and he
did these these really sort of
fantastical their their their virtual
paintings in a way but this is again a
way of sort of connecting our past
history of manifest destiny with our
current Imperial policies abroad sets
that work and then I'm almost to the end
here this is an ongoing series called
thrift drones where I'm actually going
into thrift stores and buying strange
thrift store art and putting drones into
them this is actually the finished
version of this work is going to be
shown at the sonoma valley museum of art
in march or next year and these will be
shown in a in salon style
which basically means the entire wall
and it's going to be much tighter than
this and the when when the exhibition is
over my plan is to actually
strategically return all of these images
to thrift stores so they go back into
circulation and people will come across
them and you know again it's a bit like
the drones on the dollars to gaming
again so in first-person shooters right
like metal varner other games you
generally have teams that are equally
matched right there's equal agency
between the two sides I had this idea to
make a game about drone warfare problem
with drone warfare is there is no equal
agency right how do you make something
interesting and engaging a meaningful
out of complete agency and complete
non-agency right and so I work with
these collaborators in Scotland and we
have created a game that is called kill
box a game about drone warfare and
essentially when you play this game you
start we show this as installation it's
also available it will be available
online to play but you sit across a
table from each other and you play as
either a drone pilot or the civilian in
North Waziristan and you play through
the process of a drone strike from
either point of view and then after the
drone strike and the villagers killed
you switch roles so you get perspective
the perspective from both sides um peace
have been shown all over the world at
festivals and actually working right now
and hopefully getting this shown in
Karachi and the next month but it's it's
this way of creating an experience that
would perhaps create empathy or critical
understanding or some sort of simulation
of what that experience is like and
what's been fascinating with this it's
very simple game actually not much fun
is that when people play it and they're
their neck neo they're facing each other
and then the drone strike happens you
see this kind of realization like whoa
wait you just did that to me you know
kind of thing and it it creates kind of
it's a bird's gameplay in a way and I
think a very interesting and meaningful
way finally to last projects this is one
that is ongoing these are some
statistics from the bureau of
investigative journalism about drone
strikes this is a map created from a
project called metadata which you used
to be able to get from the apple store
but they took it off and it's a map of
all 424 drone strikes in North
Waziristan what I'm working on it is a
project with a collaborator Pete
Crossley from University Oklahoma and
our goal is to print a 3d printed paper
drone one for each drone strike and then
create a kind of map room installation
that and this is using an m corp printer
which is a wonderful paper printer and
essentially create this map of drone
strikes and what we've done is a
prototype so far this is 30 drone
strikes around the town of mir ali and
we've created a kind of test
installation and then essentially each
drone is on a peg and a stand and they
have a an addressable LED light that our
idea is that when the full installation
is made and it's like it doesn't want to
work sorry about that when the
installation actually works what will
happen is those lights will go off in a
chronology of drone strikes across the
map so it will be like this you know
this is the process and as it's going it
creates these these shadows these swarms
of drones across the ceiling in motion
and kind of chaos it's a it's a work in
progress we hope eventually to be able
to show this inside of a museums be a
museum or gallery space installed in
what are called Drash tents which is the
current military kind of mash hospital
tents and command and control but there
are these low polygon things that kind
of pop up and they have a white interior
so what we want to do is basically have
these shadows kind of in this space but
that's a work in progress and finally in
February of 2016 I got access to
new dick cheney statue that was unveiled
in the capital in 2015 it's not in a
publicly accessible area of the capital
i got permission through Harry Reid's
office in Nevada told them I wanted to
document it for my research and I
actually am okay well scared actually
took photos for photogrammetry and
actually 3d scanned the statue with an i
sent scanner and my intention is to do a
publicly sourced crowd-sourced project
where i share the 3d data of the bust
online and invite people to do what they
will mess with dick if you will it's
it's an ongoing project is not quite
launched yet but i hope to launch this
soon anyway that's me some of me go
ahead entertain any questions comments
etc so thank you very much got a few
minutes questions comments I can't leave
without asking school nobody yeah so in
America really got like voted out of the
teens did that the people or something
anything ever McDaniel count no I I was
I I thought that might happen and
actually the the first time I got
contacted by a reporter I think it was a
I think it was a woman from salon and
she said oh after I talked to young and
be talking to the developers of the game
what do you think they're going to say
and I was like although they're probably
going to boot me or something and and
and they didn't actually and every
reporter we talked to me after that got
the same answer from the developers and
they basically had like this boilerplate
thing that said you know all players are
welcome unless they're interfering with
the gameplay of others or using foul and
offensive language etc so they they let
it go they didn't do anything about it I
did hear through the grapevine from a
friend who works at USC or some of the
game developers were that that those
particular folks actually appreciated
when I was doing so kind of interesting
but yeah I thought that would happen but
it did now the questions yeah Devon in
Iraq did you hear from people like
parents yeah I did and that was actually
I was really worried about that and
thought about that piece for a long time
before I did it because of that um I got
I've got I got I got a I got an email
from the mother of a soldier died he was
thankful for what I was doing the one
that was probably most intense was a
brother of a soldier who died and he
emailed me a long message very
respectful but his brother had died in
the war in any setting respectfully my
brother supported his mission and he was
aware of the game he didn't think he had
played it but that and he asked me not
to include his brother's name in the
project and you know I I figured
something that was going to happen and I
you know it really kind of pushed me to
a place of really kind of solidifying my
reasoning behind the project and I i
sent him probably a three-page email and
was essentially said to him like look
here's my here's my here's where this
project came from him why I'm doing this
I had seen a sign in Reno that said yeah
you know everything was like support our
troops support our troops and all that
and by 2003-2004 you know I saw sign
that said remember our troops you know
like like and Andy I wasn't in our
consciousness right I me it was like
this thing that was happening to other
people and part of my reasoning to him
was that look like we have been
disallowed from seeing flag covered
coffins coming home from the war as soon
as you're as soon as you die it's the
family's responsibility to mourn and and
your brother died for me and everybody
in this country like like it's like
we're part of this and this is my way as
a citizen of the hardest of actually
connecting to this tragedy that is going
on and and n2 and just to actually even
just like read through the list of names
and it's it's like print it out it's
like that thick
4500 something names it's just I mean
there were times I was doing the project
I was weeping you know and and so I
described the scepter min but and and he
was you know really he was we respect we
agreed to disagree and eventually he and
I were actually interviewed on NPR
together in dialogue and we talked to
each other about an hour and and it was
great it was actually really nice to
talk to the guy with a with an
interviewer and I kind of in between
what was fascinating though was that one
wish when it was actually went online or
went on the radio is it was edited down
to conflict like even NPR you know it's
like it was kind of it was good it's a
good interview but it was still kind of
surprising but I guess shouldn't have
been that was but that was a really sir
pivotal moment in the project definitely
but since then I mean it was I got
there's comments by veterans pro con
gamers there were some gamers who
actually one of more interesting
experiences was a guy from the school
paper unr all it was really fascinating
cuz reporters they all generally has the
same questions and they all tend to be a
little lazy they like they read each
other's stories and they write the same
stuff well this guy he's like he
actually went on to the americas army
website and he created a post on their
forum and saying hey anyone come into
contact with this guy doing this protest
the american army game and before the
americas army folks deleted his request
he got contacted by some kid and he said
oh yeah and they told him nenaaa light
up talking to this kid and the kid said
yeah me and my buddy were in the
americas army game we saw what this guy
was doing so we went and stood in front
of him and protected him and and I had
remembered that I had remembered like I
thought there were these two guys in
front of me and I thought they were AFK
you know away from keyboard and they
took the bullets for me before I gotcha
and I email I explained it up emailing
the kid I was I was like did you really
do this like I remember this thing he
said oh yeah that was us
says if you let us know when you're
going in what will go in with you okay
so it was like this you know there was
all kinds of responses and that that i
thought was was quite quite fascinating
are the questions someone yes is a
certain multi-part but I mean you
mentioned that you were an artist in
residence at like a large technology
company months I was pleased you could
talk a little bit about how they opened
up that space view and also if you have
just more general thoughts on the
implications of like large technology
companies and the sort of
infrastructural things that you're
talking about and could we talk more
simply Bob government but I mean yeah
well known that the technology companies
play a major role like the so autodesk
was fascinating like so so i did that
residency at high be Martin technology
and that was more of a non-profit they
brought in people who essentially
interviewed all the residents and it was
everyone was interested in open source
and kind of you know collaboration and
it was about making art and you know
exploring design that everything at
Autodesk you know a different situation
and and there I I felt very
uncomfortable in our desk it was amazing
I mean that access to they have probably
on the best digital fabrication
facilities on the planet right some of
your probably been there like they do
tours and stuff but it was this kind of
corporate Silicon Valley kind of you
know they feed everybody and it's all
happy and kind of looks like
kindergarten workspace and all you know
and amazing and I'm not it's not like to
be critical of that it was really
fascinating being in that environment
but the the work that I was doing just
didn't fit there like I got lots of
interesting it created these interesting
points of dialogue where I got some
people are like so what is it about
drones you're not like like what the
military like like there was just this
like not it was bringing this way of
thinking about technology and expression
and art into a context where it really
wasn't autodesk and the whole thing is
it's about making it's making the future
and it's this really kind of techno
positive kind of
thing and so that kind of critical
message I didn't always feel like it
gelled there I think I made it work for
me Ben and there were some I did feel
some conflicts about that there was one
point I remember I was in the 3d
printing lab I think I was make trying
to make a cast of drones before I got to
the paper thing and there was actually a
guy who was printing he was 3d printing
a model of like a battleship or some
kind of navy vessel that was going to be
given to some Admiral who was
instrumental in autodesk getting some
big Defense Department contracting and
it was one of those things I was just
like like where the [ __ ] am I like what
you know what but that's it's not my my
thinking on those things is it's like
the as an hardest to go in and
experience that is important and and I
can't claim that I'm somehow outside of
that context I mean my tax dollars are
at work right now as are yours right we
are part of this and so I I don't know
if it was a it was fascinating and hand
a little bit scary but also like that's
reality we function and an auto dust I
mean they do some great work they have
some other like design for change stuff
going on but yeah so much of where we're
sitting right now is to looking value be
your department probably lots of defense
work all that kind of stuff I mean we're
all part of this right it's a huge thing
in our country that I think I'm doing
I'm trying to do what I do best which is
make strange things that perhaps make
you think her and to me faut eventually
could lead to change I don't know if
that's true or not but I have to be
hopeful right other questions
no there's not um I think we look like
with those work that your dad the
schools and sort of the instructable
things there seems to be like I don't
know it's fair to say I'll push towards
like sharing information but hoping that
people also collaborate with you and
maybe work on their own projects are
learning about your relationship the
relationship with your work to like
engaging the community and whether you
have intentions for them to do something
similar how you said yeah yeah so I
didn't show the first instructable I put
up for an art project was actually the
Gandhi the cardboard Gandhi and I
documented the whole process as I went
along because i'm not i'm not super
high-tech and like figuring out how to
actually do the treadmill thing actually
found a couple hacks i think one was on
instructables one is somewhere and I
like use these things I was like wow
that's great that I got that information
let's see maybe I'll share something
back you know as I put a documented the
entire process of making the Gandhi and
I made a huge instructable that went on
there and it's it got featured in their
book and all this kind of stuff but the
one of the most rewarding things was I
got at least and over at least two
people who landed up making projects
based on that and one of them was a was
a teenager in Mexico and he sent me a
picture of this enormous low polygon
gorilla he made and he was so proud you
know and I was just kind of like and
there's a guy in Singapore who's
actually was inspired by the work and he
now makes cardboard cardboard low
polygon stuff that's his job like he
makes these big sculptures and he does
like he just did a good thing from
Pokemon go and all it you know and and
he's a friend i don't know him but you
know like that i like that's great i
think that's that's part of this and and
my hope is that there's someone there
are some things done it works like i got
contacted by a group called scada Stan
which is a non-profit they do schools
primarily for girls and they have two in
Afghanistan one in South Africa one in
Cambodia and they have schools and they
have skate parks and it's a bunch of
skate
who started this thing and they go to
these places and they they teach him but
they also learn how to skate you've seen
those picture of afghan girls in the
skate gear probably online it's them and
they they asked me to possibly come and
do a workshop to build something with
their with their kids you know and that
kind of thing I was like ah um they're
like that's I love that kind of stuff I
think that kind of you know
cross-cultural dialogue and art you know
changing people i think is really
important something I'm very excited
about but I love that and it was
something that came out of working at
eyebeam as well because the like in the
in the contemporary art world and in
like the University where I work it's
like it's very competitive like the art
world is like who gets the idea first
and who's that he oh there's not a whole
lot of sharing and went to I beam and it
was all about sharing it was all about
like every week they had stopped work
sessions and everybody stopped work and
if you wanted to share something and ask
a question like hey how do I do this and
that's like I went and I said hey I got
this data from second life I want to
make a giant Gandhi and I'm looking at
this and some guy said oh go check out
pepakura papercraft you know like and it
was this gesture of sharing and it was
open like that it wasn't this it wasn't
artists who were like preening like I'll
look what I've done and I've got this
show on that show was genuinely people
interested in helping and collaborating
with each other and to me that's what we
need to make everything better right and
so that that became core I think
especially in turning towards politics
in the work was this kind of ability to
use that to try to connect as opposed to
just make oneself you know ego-driven
famous whatever that this other stuff is
much more rewarding in the comments
yes see more about scotton what attracts
you there well so I've been in reno for
23 years I raised my daughter's there
they're both in New York doing very well
one's a playwright one's going to med
school soon it's been a year of divorce
big changes the University of Nevada
Reno has been good but it's a very
casual is well I'm in a school of the
arts and I remain after 23 years the
only person hired to deal with digital
media and I see no it's just not
happening and they approached me at the
University abertay this last summer and
it's a hundred percent research role and
they I was the first thing that came up
when they came up with this position and
it just looks like a good fit and they
want me to come in and do my work work
with collaborative teams of course will
be fundraising grant writing that kind
of thing but it's just not for too good
an opportunity to pass up and the month
that I spent in abertay as are not in
Dundee wasn't even connected to abertay
at the time but there's a there's an
interesting density there of media based
practitioner and design it's just it's
the right time right place we'll see
what happens and also I think living
abroad will will probably change my
focus of it I think anytime I've
traveled abroad you get a very different
perspective on how the rest of the world
views us you know and so to be part of
that from a distance and also still
engaged here traveling back and forth
it's it's just time for a change pretty
excited about it ionno time 20-item
above Scotland Yard o / st. Columba was
with this okay bringing Christianity to
the people of Scotland even connect with
them cool i'll have to look it up
anyways well thank you thank you slowly
making a skier but all you're working if
anyone has any last questions I'm sure I
can come a faster system okay leave a
mess thanks i don't need make good stuff